this is one of my favorite examples
about how physicists
develop intuition it goes to the work of
galileo
so you know again let's go back to greek
philosophers or maybe aristotle in this
case
now again let's let's make a criticism
he thought that objects
the heavier objects fall faster than the
lighter objects makes sense
it kind of makes sense and you know
people say about feather and so on but
that's because of the air resistant but
you might think like if you have a heavy
stone and a light pebble the heavy one
will fall first if you don't
you know do any experiments that's the
first gut reaction i would say everybody
would say that's the natural thing
galileo did not believe this and he kind
of um
did the experiment famously it said he
went on the top of pizza tower and he
dropped you know these heavy and light
stones and they fell at the same time
when they he dropped at that same time
from the same height okay good so he
said i'm done you know i've showed that
the
heavy and lighter objects fought the
same time i did the experiment
scientists at that time did not accept
it
why was that because at that time
science was not just
experimental the experiment was not
enough
they didn't think that they have to sort
their hands in doing experiments to get
to the reality they said why is it the
case
why so galileo had to come up with an
explanation of why heavier and lighter
objects fought the same ray
this is the way he convinced them using
symmetry
he said suppose you have three bricks
the same
shape the same size
same as everything and we hold these
three bricks at the same height
and drop them which one will fall to the
ground
first everybody said of course we know
that symmetry
tells you know they're all the same
shape same size same height
of course they fall at the same time
yeah we know that next next
it's trivial he says okay what if we
move these bricks around with the same
height does it change the time they hit
the ground
they said if it's the same height again
by the symmetry principle because the
height translation horizontal transition
the symmetry
no it doesn't matter they all fall the
same rate good doesn't matter how close
i bring them together no it doesn't
okay suppose i make the two bricks touch
and then let them go do they follow the
same rate
yes they do but they said well the two
bricks that touch
are twice more mass than this other
brick and you just agreed that they
fought the same rate
they say yeah yeah we just agreed that's
right that's strange yes
so he deconfused them by the symmetry
design so this way
of repackaging some intuition a
different intuition
when the intuitions clash then you then
you decide on the you replace the
intuition
that's brilliant i i in some of these
diff
more difficult physical ideas
physics ideas in the 20th century in the
21st century it starts becoming more and
more difficult to then replace the
intuition
you know what what does the world look
like for an object traveling close to
the speed of light
you start to think about like the edges
of supermassive black holes
and you start to think like what what's
that look like
or uh i've been re into gravitational
waves recently
it's like when the fabric of space time
is being morphed
by gravity like what's that actually
feel like
if i'm writing a gravitational wave
what's that feel like
um i mean i think some of those are more
sort of
hippie not useful uh
intuitions to have but if you're an
actual physicist
or whatever the particular discipline is
i wonder if it's possible to meditate
to sort of uh escape through thinking
prolonged thinking and meditation on a
war
on a world like live in a visualized
world that's not like our own
in order to understand a phenomenon
deeply so like replace the intuition
like through rigorous meditation on the
idea
in order to conceive of it i mean if we
talk about multiple dimensions
i wonder if there's a a way to escape
with the three-dimensional world
in our mind in order to then start to
reason about it
it's uh the more i talk to topologists
the more they seem to not operate at all
at all in the visual space
they really trust the mathematics like
which is really annoying to me because
topology
and differential geometry feels like it
has a lot of potential for beautiful
pictures
yes i think they do actually i would not
be able to
do my my research if i don't have an
intuitive feel about geometry
and i i will get to it as you mentioned
late uh before that
how for example in strength there you
deal with these extra dimensions and
i'll be very happy
to describe how we do it because with
that intuition we will not get anywhere
and i
i don't think you can just rely on
formalism i don't
i don't think any physicist just relies
on formalism that's not physics that's
not understanding
so we have to intuit it and that's
crucial and this there are steps of
doing it and we learned it might not be
trivial
but we learned how to do it similar to
this galileo picture i just told you
you have to build these gradually but
but you connect the bricks exactly you
have to connect the bricks
literally yeah so yeah so then so
going back to your question about this
the path of the history of the science
so i was
saying about the electricity magnesium
and the special relativity where simple
idea
led to special relativity but then he
went further
thinking about acceleration in the
context of relativity and he came up
with general relativity
where he talked about you know the
fabric of space time being curved and so
forth and
matter affecting the the the curvature
of the space on time so
so this gradually became
a connection between geometry and
physics namely he replaced newton's
you know gravitational force with
a very geometrical beautiful picture
it's much more elegant than newton's but
much more complicated mathematically
so so when we say it's simpler we mean
in some form it's simpler but not in
pragmatic terms of equation solving the
equations are
much harder to solve in either science
theory and in fact so much
so much harder that einstein himself
couldn't solve many of his many of the
cases he thought for example you
couldn't solve the equation for a
spherical symmetric matter uh like like
if you had this symmetric sun
he didn't think you can actually write
the solve his equation for that and
a year after he he said that it was
solved by by short child so it was
it was that hard that he didn't think
it's going to be that easy so yeah the
formalism is hard
but the contrast between the special
relativity and general relativity is
very interesting because one of them has
almost trivial math
and the other one has super complicated
math
both are physically amazingly important
and so so we have learned that you know
the physics
may or may not require complicated math
we should not shy from using complicated
math like einstein did
nobody einstein wouldn't say i'm not
going to touch this math because it's
too much you know
tensors or you know curvature and i
don't like four-dimensional space-time
because i haven't seen four-dimension
he wasn't doing that he was willing to
abstract from that because
physics drove him in that direction but
his motivation was physics physics
pushed him
just like newton pushed to develop
calculus because physics pushed him that
he didn't have the tools so he had to
develop the tools
to answer his physics questions so his
motivation was physics again
so to me those are examples which showed
that math and physics have this
symbiotic reality relationship which
which kind of reinforce each other here
i'm using i'm giving you examples
of both of them namely newton's work led
to development of mathematics calculus
and in the case of einstein he didn't
develop the premium geometry just use
them
so so it goes both ways and in the
context of modern physics we see that
again and again it goes both ways
you